but back to the cleveland browns the
team that now is moving in the right
direction the browns is the browns no
more andrew barry the general manager
of the browns appearing on the ross
tucker football podcast discussing the
theory of extending players specifically
quarterbacks after three years and the
cautionary tale provided by carson wentz
and jared goff here's andrew barry
i i think it is fair to say that that is
an approach that we believe in in terms
of
um you know identifying you know pillar
guys and and trying to retain them as
soon as we can now that being said each
situation
um truly is you know truly is unique
um but you know we do want to get into a
habit of rewarding our own and um
you know uh
identifying those guys
is is there a cautionary tale
with the trades of wence and goff
this off season and the contracts that
they signed after their third year i
don't i think it's maybe a bit too
strong to call them cautionary tales
because i truly do believe each
individual and then um each individual's
situation
based on the circumstances that are
going on in their environment of their
organization um are different
yeah obviously it's something that that
we're aware of and obviously i'm
particularly aware of it just you know
with you know with carson um but i would
i would be hesitant to maybe over
extrapolate extrapolate perhaps what
happened with you know with those two
individuals you know for maybe broader
implications um moving forward
look i i can i can make this very simple
uh
you got a decision to make if you're the
cleveland browns the longer you wait the
more expensive it's gonna be to sign
baker mayfield and i think part of the
dance right now between mayfield josh
allen of bills lamar jackson the ravens
is whoever goes first is going to get
leapfrogged by the next guy who's going
to get leapfrogged by the next guy so
everyone's kind of in a holding pattern
here but if you know mayfield's your guy
and only you as the gods of rounds can
know whether or not he's the guy if
you're sold on this guy completely
totally and
unconditionally yeah then you got to
sign him now because it's only going to
get more expensive later that's right if
you're not sold then you wait it's that
simple it is it is that simple mike
you're right i mean there's no other way
to put it i mean we just saw the dak
prescott thing what that did to
dallas and that issue you know so yeah
if you're sold
not like oh we think or maybe or like no
we've had three years of seeing this guy
and it's all coming together and we
believe in the human
and now we see the field stuff we
believe in too
then yeah you do it you get it for the
low i mean you get it for the patrick
mahomes discount maybe to where you get
a contract that you go
this is laughable look at what we're
paying him here you know three or four
years down the road we're gonna look
back at my homes and be like can you
believe that still that they signed him
to that deal and he was making that back
then and now look at it now and it's not
even that big of a deal so of course
that's what you do i mean so that's a
no-brainer to me the big question is is
just do they
a hundred percent feel
as if he's that guy it is it's it's you
know it's a tough one lamar listen we
know lamar's the guy he's been the mvp
and all that i think josh allen you know
between two playoff appearances in a row
and a year that he had last year where
you could argue you know other than
rogers he played second best at the
position of anybody in football
mayfield is a little different because
we saw good then we saw a lull and a
step back
and then we started last year and it was
a little slow at first but then it
really started to pick up and he started
to really be a baller at the end of the
year so that might be not quite enough
time for them to go
wait we're totally sold he's the guy yet
they're close but we're not totally sold
at least that's maybe how i would feel
is what i'm saying mike yeah you're
absolutely right but but they're the
ones who have to within the confines of
their building within the privacy of
whatever room they gather in to have
these conversations they need to have
the full and frank bless you if that was
a change they need to have the full and
frank conversation
is this our guy
can we do better desean watson may be
available next year russell wilson may
be available next year chris what what
what was the the possibility it was
dangled to the browns three years ago
russell wilson for the first overall
pick not that it ever got very far but
the conversation was out there russell
wilson born in ohio by the way so
look
teams
always
assess their roster
not in a vacuum
it's assessed in relation to who else is
out there that they think they can get
and they will
ruthlessly
make a move from one guy to another guy
if they think number one there's a path
a clear path to getting him and number
two that he's an upgrade yeah over who
they have right and
until baker mayfield is regarded as the
best quarterback in all of football and
he ain't there yet could be could be i'm
not going to slam the door on the
possibility but until he's regarded as
the best quarterback in football
there's always a potential upgrade the
question is is there a path a realistic
path for you to get that upgrade because
if you can and you don't there's
something wrong with you so
they only know how they feel about baker
mayfield that's right and how they feel
about their other options for next year
and maybe they give it one more year
maybe they wait and see if mayfield
finds a higher level of performance in
his second season with kevin stefanski
as the head coach and they also see
could aaron rodgers be available could
russell wilson be available could desean
watson be available could there be
someone else who becomes available what
if the what if the vikings decide
they're
they'd like to move on from kirk cousins
after this year go to calamond and kevin
stefanski says you know what i'm more
comfortable with cousins i was with him
for multiple years in minnesota i think
he can do more in this offense than
baker mayfield i'm not saying that he
should feel that way but you can't rule
anything like that out if they're sold
on mayfield completely sign him now if
they're not let it play out you got two
more years of his rookie contract let it
play out so i think that and and it all
starts with the browns having
a consensus if they can reach one on how
they feel about baker mayfield yeah that
that that's it i and you know i would
think they're pretty close i would just
from the outside looking in i mean i
think you and i saw some pretty damn
good high level football in the last you
know six weeks of the year into the
playoffs to where we were like man baker
mayfield it's he's throwing dimes
everywhere it's it's it's aggressive you
know on the richter scale the degree of
difficulty of some of the throws he's
asked to make are pretty damn high there
so you know i think what we're saying
here is
when you know you have a quarterback
that you start to look at to go wait
our guy is
one of the 10 best quarterbacks in
football and he's had a spot here where
he's gonna be in the top 10 for a number
of years you make that where you start
to go even in a bad year he's going to
be the 10th best quarterback in football
that's when you go
let's sign them up and i would think
that you got to be close i could see the
cleveland browns thing mike being a
little bit of like
hey they start out 3-1 baker hit the
ground running left off where he was
last year and they go we're sold let's
start getting this done right now so we
don't have to worry about it in the off
season and have to hear all this stuff i
could very much envision that type of
scenario
well and the other side of it too is
what does baker mayfield want and we
just always assume that a guy who's
playing for a team wants to play for
that team indefinitely meanwhile russell
wilson wants out of seattle aaron
rodgers wants out of green bay and
deshawn watson wants out of houston i
have no reason to think baker mayfield
wants to be anything other than the
quarterback of the cleveland browns no i
also i also know enough about baker
mayfield and i respect this about him
he's not just going to sit back and be a
passenger
on the ride that is his nfl career he's
going to be an active participant i
think that's part of this too not that
i'm saying he would be inclined to
refuse
any and all contract extensions and play
the franchise tag game and eventually
put himself in position where maybe he
can go back to texas and be the
quarterback in houston or go wherever
else he may decide to go i'm not saying
that but that's part of it as well it's
not a one-way street yeah um and uh for
now though the threshold question is
what do the browns want to do and if
he's the guy it's that simple if he's
the guy you sign him now andrew barry
go ahead
i want to pivot to something else but go
ahead just one last thing because i do
want to bring up like the cautionary
tale thing right that aspect that's what
i was getting too okay i was getting too
can i i'll just make my one of my
blanket statement i understand yeah the
rams the eagles those scenarios are
gonna be looked at no doubt about it but
i don't think like andrew berry i think
what he was trying to say is you gotta
take each like circumstance in its own
individual
you know capacity there a little bit
the eagles
they made a move on carson wentz he had
shown some stuff that was pretty damn
special
so i understand that
and i will also say that
i'm not sitting here
at this point even necessarily going i
think they made the wrong decision and
giving him that money where they went
wrong is you gave a guy all this money
it did nothing to support him and then
you drafted jalen hurts and your
quarterback was already in a
controversial situation so the eagles
kind of disrupted that formula in my
opinion and then when you talk about the
rams and jared goff to me this is a
simple case
it's a total misevaluation of a player
and letting the circumstance of our team
and he's a california kid and everybody
here that's a rams fan from california
thinks he's god and they just buckled to
it oh he's the guy let's give it to him
so that was they were wrong
i can say the rams are wrong the eagles
there was a few things that set that
forth but like we've talked about you
know i would be worried about a dak
prescott or a joe flacco situation or
something like that and that's why if
you get to that point you're talking
about you make the move and you sign
signed baker mayfield
i still believe though
that
any situation where a team makes the
move to sign a quarterback after three
years and it doesn't work out is a
cautionary tale yeah i get you with
andrew barry's statement that it's a bit
too strong to call them cautionary tales
they are cautionary tales they're
different degrees different types
different contexts but let's start with
the eagles i mean look you have to
factor in the possibility that the guy's
going to lose his fastball because the
eagles apparently didn't they didn't see
it coming unless they did they end up
drafting jalen hurts i don't know what
they were thinking when they did that
but it definitely disrupted things
that's a cautionary tale of it i think
you're right like you take that into it
to be the caution you look at the whole
you look at the whole experience right
you look at the whole experience and
basically if you're going to make
a guy
the guy and given the contract
you can't be screwing around with using
second round picks on quarterbacks
exactly first round picks on jordan love
or no receiver guy yeah the guy right
with the rams the rams just blew it
right there's no other way to put it
yeah they just blew it yeah and we all
knew they were gonna do it we all knew
it was coming we all said don't do it
and i feel like at some level and i
remember i think it was fred rogan with
the nbc affiliate in la and he has a
radio show out there and he had me on
and called me out because i was saying
don't do it don't do it don't do it and
and he and he did this interview with
sean mcvay and acted like it's so
ridiculous to suggest that jared goff
shouldn't get a second contract it's
like fine go ahead do it i eventually
it's like kind of like where we are with
the jaguars and teamwork tim tebow
you're gonna do it fine go ahead do it
better better for us if you do it
because we can sit back and watch it all
fall apart and guess what it all fell
apart so that one truly is the
cautionary tale you got to be 100 sold
on the quarterback he can't be a product
of the system he can't be a guy that
just fits some some broader image that
you have of what your quarterback is
gonna is gonna be it can't be we have to
pay the quarterback a ton of money
because we need the other guys in the
locker room yeah that's not the right
reason that's not the solution right
yeah and it's not just well he's the
next guy who's do a contract so we're
gonna give him this big deal because at
the end of the day and i'm telling you i
i i really do think one of the reasons
jared goff is a lion and was part of
that matthew stafford package is because
the rams were trying to keep stan
kroenke from realizing they had to give
up a first-round pick to get jared
goff's contract off the books
that's how badly they screwed this up
that the thinking is from the people
i've spoken to it was a one and a three
for stafford and a first-round pick to
the lions to take on that horrendous
jared goff contract so that's definitely
a cautionary tale definitely and the
tale is you if you're not sure
don't sign the guy that's right yeah
well you when you put it that way you're
right they're all cautionary tales so
i'll stand back i'll i'll i'll say that
i will correct myself and saying that
yes it's just not apples to apples you
gotta take take each story as its own
and go wait okay wait all right that's a
cautionary tale let's not do that
when we sign our guy or whatever else so
uh i i would think it's really close to
be into that territory with baker
mayfield listen i think we're there with
josh allen you tell me if you agree with
that or not you know i think josh josh
allen now right now right exactly like
what are you gonna do wait for him to
throw 52 touchdown passes and 75
highlight plays this year so that's
scary
lamarr i you know again same thing i'd
say now too
you know it's a little different because
of his running back running quarterback
and all that but i would still say no do
it now get it for the low who knows the
ravens are good they could go to the
super bowl he could be the super bowl
mvp and then you're going oh damn we got
to pay him an extra seven million
dollars a year just because of that so
that's that's the things you got to
worry about but i think lamar and josh
allen do it now baker mayfield i think
if i'm cleveland i might want to just
see the start of the year and see how it
starts rolling a little bit before i do
that i just want to see one little more
piece of evidence to make me feel good
and comfortable that it's all going in
the right way
i think for the ravens there's a a
couple of challenges that they need to
confront one you want to structure the
deal in a way that gives you an out if
within a couple of years the injuries
begin to pile up lamar jackson's been
fine so far but given the style of play
you never know when things are going to
start to not hold up physically for
lamar jackson as he gets deeper into his
20s you don't want to have these
guarantees that tie your hands for three
four five six years so that needs to be
part of it the other side of it is this
chris and i asked eric to cost about it
a couple weeks ago on pftpm what kind of
challenges you face when you're not
negotiating with a player who's
represented by a traditional nflpa
certified agent
and and we didn't get
all the way down the rabbit hole in fact
we didn't get very far down the rabbit
hole because decosta didn't even begin
to go there but there's a temptation if
you're a team negotiating with a player
who doesn't have a traditional agent
there's a temptation to overreach of
course there's there's a there's always
a temptation to to get away with things
that other agents would notice that any
agent right would notice that you know a
caa a todd france the david dunn the
quarterback agents you can't pull that
on them
you can pull that on
someone who's representing himself being
advised by his mom and by some lawyer
that they know or some accountant that
they know who doesn't do this for a
living
but thinks that they know enough that
they can do it no no
there's nuances there's factors and
there's temptations to take advantage
and not say
you know and this is the balance that
the cost is going to have to strike
good long-term partner we're looking out
for our guy right versus
best interest of the organization
it's better for us to have this clause
in there and they have no idea what that
clause means let's just jump through and
they're not going to figure it out
that's that's the dilemma that i think
you face when you're dealing with a guy
who isn't represented by one of the top
quarterback agents yeah yeah i agreed
100
you better be careful if you're
baltimore even in that scenario there
like yeah they might finagle some things
in their advantage they got to be
careful
because if they do screw over a player
the caliber of a lamar jackson or
anything like that that will of course
be huge news nobody will like the ravens
players will look at them differently
and their locker room will but you're
right there's still things that they're
going to be able to get away with their
finagle that's why the agent and that's
why to me hey paying the three percent
is a no-brainer a no-brainer you know
it's like you you broke it down i was
represented by tom conde in my playing
days yeah he knows between his personal
relationships nuances of how to
negotiate nuances of the cba knowing how
the salary cap works and how teams
different teams operate and oh this guy
this gm does this and does this like
those are things that a that a great
agent can bring to the table he can give
you a lot of security for the bad things
that happen and also
maximize
everything you need as far as just like
your top end stuff too and i i if i
could tell lamar jackson i'd tell him to
get an agent for sure
this is something that richard sherman
and russell okung really tried to
spearhead a few years ago taking it
beyond what's right for them and trying
to encourage other players to believe it
was right for them the bottom line is
you get yourself a good agent
you're going to have
a larger pie from which you get 97
versus the smaller pie from what you get
a hundred percent yeah it's it's always
been
that
simple
and it continues to be that simple and
fortunately other players haven't signed
on to this idea that we don't need our
own agents and that tension is still out
there i'm telling you it's still out
there and it's been highlighted in
recent weeks by the fact that the union
which regulates the agents has wanted
the players not to show up and the
agents intervene and say to their
clients don't listen yeah to the union
on this
listen to yourself
listen to me listen to what your
contract has to to say
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports